we love to play a quick roundup
or dare
and we have charlie gibbs chimney here
hi charlie hi charlie
you look so cute in that bright purple
thank you that dress is i'm matching you
guys yes
electric that's right we all get the
memo
all right let's get down to business
what's it going to be charlie truth or
dare
i want to know what's the longest either
of you have ever gone without taking a
bath
um
i you know that sexy thing people have
when they're like oh they're kind of
dirty and that's hot
yes i do love that smell and i love when
it gets all over a boyfriend's t-shirt
and then you can keep the t-shirt
and like just wear it and snuggle with
it in bed come on you must have had that
experience
i'm good i shower every day you
understand i know look at him i i i feel
i i believe you ross thank you thank you
i believe it or not don't have that bad
boy musk
that's that's what i like
bad boy
yeah yeah what about you how long do you
go without taking a shower here's the
deal
i can totally not wash my hair for like
a week in fact the natural oils like
rocket little dry shampoo but i can't go
that long with the body like i that is
where i draw the line like i've got to
wash me bits you know yeah i gotta keep
it clean
um and then i wash my face two to three
times a day minimum understood so it's
like the hair i can let that go for a
week but the face and the body is it's a
it's a regular thing yeah but you like
your guys to have a little funkadoo i
want that bad boy musk yeah you do how
is that not a perfume
can i name a candle after that what
which one funkadoo no bad boy much bad
boy must yeah yeah that's way better
yeah that's so i find that cam
i have i just created the perfect set
for it i'm going to bring it to you
tomorrow and you're going to smell it
okay yes i want to smell candles right
now so i have i'm we're creating all
these fragrances and there's this one
where i'm like this is sex it's so hot
it's so such a turn-on
and oh it's been a long time yeah
sorry
it's been so long that i'm getting a
little nervous standing here actually
that she might just pounce wow
thank you for asking this question
[Music]
you